80 million years ago dinosaurs ruled the
surface of planet Earth yet in the blink
of a cosmic eye this Kingdom would fall
to a mass extinction and an entirely
unexpected order of animals would take
their place if a similar Calamity were
to upend Nature's order once again what
kinds of incredible life forms might
emerge set 80 million years from now the
soul cash bestieri is a speculative
biology project by the brilliant artist
and World Builder Terry Miranda
through naturalist style illustrations
it explores a world where Humanity has
long disappeared and evolution has
drastically transformed the animals we
know today
so for this entry into the archive we'll
explore this reborn Earth and as always
you can support the artist on patreon to
see more of the project using the links
in the description now let's travel to
the distant future and discover the
creatures of the soulcash bestiary
80 million years from now the island of
solkesh is a land mass where the
extremes of the environment meet the
extremes of evolution today some of the
most extreme ecosystems are coral reefs
in the era of soulcash coral has adapted
to thrive in the intertidal zone
allowing familiar Reef life to take to
the land
one of the first pioneers of these
semi-terrestrial reefs is the tentacled
seraphal this semi-aquatic cephalopod
creeps from the ocean as the Tide Falls
feeding on mollusks and Crustaceans left
exposed to the sun incredible as this
might sound we already have some
documentation of cephalopods moving upon
the land in a limited capacity and while
the seraphole is technically more
closely related to Modern squids than
octopus 80 million years is plenty of
time for such a creature to emerge given
the right conditions seraphal tentacles
have hardened into claw-like tips for
dragging their body across the land and
for cracking open the shells of urchins
and crabs so they can Feast for like
their squid ancestors seropholes or
carnivores
but there are larger carnivores in these
reborn reefs the lancelet is a
slithering Terror that searches for The
Telltale rhythm of prey with their
sensitive antennae perhaps unexpectedly
these Ambush Predators or the
descendants of the lethargic sea slug
yet in the era of soulcash the lancelots
can move with whip-like speed able to
launch themselves at prey with deadly
accuracy and spear them with their
forward-facing prongs in the arms race
of evolution these reefs are a war zone
surveying the battlefield with their
solitary orange eye the gorill is one
particularly alien creature with four
loping limbs they stride across the sand
feeding on anything the tide dredges up
remarkably these slimy carnivores are
the descendants of mollusks although
they've evolved fleshy limbs convergent
with other land animals their unique
method of digestion produces a pearl of
sorts in their gullet made from
compressed bone when threatened by a
fearsome Predator they can expel this
Cannonball like Pearl with devastating
Force
and few predators are as fearsome as the
day lash these Serpentine Hunters live
together upon hatching and when emerging
from their Burrows resemble multi-headed
hydras an offshoot of today's Garden
eels they've retained their ancestors
habit of peeking out of the sand in
unison with exceptionally large eyes the
day lash can track and snatch up most
any stray fish that tumbles through the
current with their trap-like jaws yet
these dalash are only juveniles
Adult Day lash are large enough to hunt
alone these full-grown Terrors are
expert Hunters able to Brave a wide
variety of environments like modern
moray eels they are experts at
navigating tight corners and lashing out
from hidden Caverns to ensnare prey the
dalash or further proof that this new
reef environment is a realm of fearsome
competition
moving Inland the shore gives way to a
mosaic of swampland in our era swamps
and other Wetlands only cover around
seven percent of Earth's surface yet are
home to numerous unique life forms that
have adapted to both land and water and
80 million years in the future many of
these animals look quite different
rising to the height of a large dog the
soul Mundus slinks through the wetlands
hunting for prey while this amphibian
has become a feared Ambush predator in
the shallow ponds of these swamps their
ancestor is none other than the humble
lungless salamander the Sol mundus's
tongue is tipped with a deadly bone spur
that sits beneath their skull while at
rest to hunt the soul Mundus lashes out
with this spear-like tongue to impale
and quickly retract their prey into a
gluttonous needle-toothed Maw
in the impenetrable murk of the waters
that flood The Woodlands the murrows
sensed their surroundings clearly though
blind these gargantuan fish use their
many sensitive whiskers in combination
with low voltage electrical pulses to
detect the movement of prey much like
how their ancestors the catfish do today
creatures outside the water are equally
unsafe as this Predator can quickly
breach the opaque surface with a
vacuum-like gulp with prey instantly
disappearing into the murrow's gullet as
they sink back contently into the thick
silt
roaming in small herds across the tidal
Flats the pebbleback awk show that some
mammals still persist in this strange
future while these sheep-like creatures
might seem out of place in a swampy
environment they are well adapted for a
lifestyle that's a bit soggier than what
most mammals would put up with despite
their appearance the awk are actually a
highly derived offshoots of the
hippopotamus which are already
semi-aquatic to stay safe while wading
into Dangerous Waters the orc possess a
wide crest of horns and rows of hardened
osteoderms to deter Predators for
nightmarish creatures lurk in the depths
of the swamp
in the Sullen green light of the kelp
forest the larkira slides through the
tall plants without making a whisper
large enough to feed on other Predators
like the Murrow the larkira is a
descendant of modern freshwater fish
that has grown to a startling size
north of the swampy Coast the land gives
way to Great Untamed forests
today the world has lost over one third
of its forests due to human activity but
in the time of soulcash the forests have
rebounded in the extreme allowing
familiar woodland animals to evolve into
unfamiliar forms
tiptoeing unseen through the northern
Timberlands or the shy and skittish
frondally covered in specialized waxy
hairs that mimic leaves these
camouflaged herbivores move with the
utmost caution unsurprisingly the
frondally are relatives of modern deer
although a change in diet has led to
them becoming significantly smaller they
feed on the sap that runs through the
northern trees breaking into the bark
with their wedge-like razor jaw while
feeding the frondally keep an ear out
for potential danger and at the
slightest snap of a twig they Scurry
back into hiding
High among the Colossal conifers of
mountainous forests the calatross
quietly climbs from Branch to Branch
these avian creatures have long lost
their ability to fly with their
phalanges having regressed back into a
more digit-like form with curved claws
allowing for agile climbing the calatras
are a close genetic descendant of barn
owls and while they've lost their
ability to fly in the branches the
calatras have found a new niche as one
of the most versatile omnivores of the
new world
while one lineage exits the skies
another is just starting to stretch
their wings the basilos Spree are a
member of a reptilian genus that is
re-evolving powered flight following in
the footsteps of pterosaurs millions of
years earlier while still in suited for
long periods of flight the wing beats a
basilos spree might soon be heard across
the skies of soulcash
in speaking of making noise a colossal
omnivore barges through the deep forest
the jodus are so large they can topple
small trees with the heavy trod of their
Hooves and carve a path through leagues
of Woodland in their endless pursuit of
food a super-sized descendant of modern
pigs the jodus have retained the
boundless appetite of their ancestors
this Mighty genus has sustained its size
with a slow metabolism for there is
little reason for such a massive Beast
to hurry especially with their rock hard
hide in spiny fur
an immense network of cave systems winds
through the mountains of solkesh in our
era the vast majority of underground
chasms remain unexplored and in the
depths we have charted the life forms
within have been much changed by their
eons in isolation given 80 million more
years who knows what might evolve
in The Haunting glow of bioluminescent
fungus A sightless Terror clambers along
the dripping stalactites mollux dwell in
the darkness in large colonies
navigating their maze-like home through
echolocating chirps a species of bat
that adapted to a flightless lifestyle
while venturing even deeper into the
tunnels Maliks no longer have any need
to return to the surface they are
completely at home in the Deep hydrogen
sulfide based ecosystems that bloom far
from the light having long forgotten the
warmth of the Sun
scuttling along the ceilings walls and
floors of the Southeastern caves or the
bizarre malasite these well camouflaged
carnivores resemble living stalagmites
and drag in prey with their long
prehensile tongue the malachite are a
highly derived offshoot of scaly foot
gastropods and like their ancestors can
incorporate inorganic material into
their shells for protection yet the
malasite have found another use for the
silica they extract from the cave
tunnels having evolved away to hone the
substance into sharp obsidian-like teeth
in the tight confines of the Limestone
cavities that riddle the Western
Coastland the sightless cranus Live and
Die in utter Darkness these eel-like
creatures can search for the faintest
pulse of heat from prey using highly
sensitive heat pits along the sides of
their head having evolved from snakes
that became accustomed to life in the
dark pits over Millennia the cranas
haven't lost the Venom of their
predecessors to administer their
venomous strike the cranus possesses
forward-facing fangs they use to spear
their prey in the narrow tunnels of the
Underground
in the deepest Limestone caves the
enormous tarakni reign supreme a mighty
arachnid the tarachni uses its powerful
front limbs to break through the tough
shells of its preferred prey while today
the size of spiders is limited by the
level of oxygen in Earth's atmosphere
arthropods in the soulcash timeline have
evolved a more efficient means of
respiration allowing them to grow to
sizes not seen since the Carboniferous
period
extensive channels of spherical openings
provide the turokni with extra oxygen
giving it the fuel needed to support its
thick exoskeleton in armored limbs
back on the surface a mighty
uninterrupted grassland stretches across
much of soulcash in our era grasslands
are home to some of the largest land
animals on our planet 80 million years
into the future a new kingdom of giants
might emerge
slowly plotting across the flower fields
of Western soulcash the mighty Rue
towards churn up the Earth in search of
deep soil tubers protected from
predators by a thick external shell
these herbivores are unlike any of the
megafauna seen on The Plains today for
root warts or another distant relative
of arthropods able to grow far larger
than their ancestors due to their highly
efficient oxygen intake in a more
complex internal support structure and
thanks to their docile temperament
certain birds have learned to nest on
the backs of these mild mannered Giants
amid the footsteps of the behemoths the
quick pitter-patter of Talon feet
resonates over the dry plains as the
axolot rushes past these flightless
avian creatures are scavengers in a
world of goliaths digging into carcasses
with their sharp wedge-shaped beaks
today numerous birds have traded in
flight for a life on the ground although
nunner is peculiar as the axolot unlike
most birds the axolot does not nurture
their young instead leaving their eggs
burrowed in the soil after a longer
incubation than most birds the
fledglings are born with the ability to
run and hide from the titans of the
Plains
one of the mightiest beasts dwells in
the Rock strewn dust bowl of the Western
Plains the grok Nash are covered from
snout to spiked tail in thick armored
plates sharp enough to frighten all but
the most ferocious of predators these
standoffish creatures are descended from
one of the many spiny reptile lineages
that dwell in the deserts of today and
to take their armor to the next level
the grok Nash are known to lick stones
and mineral deposits to build up silica
within their bodies further
strengthening their plating
wherever massive tunnels Mar the surface
of the Plains okorook is surely nearby
timid and almost apologetic in
appearance these herbivores feed on
deep-rooted Plants they chew with their
large shearing teeth the koruk have
retained both the scaly armor plating
and the spade-like claws of their
Pangolin ancestors the claws of the
koruk aren't just for digging though but
also serve as an effective deterrent to
mid-sized predators
yet some predators aren't deterred so
easily with whooping howls the Monstrous
drafters tear across the Northern Plains
these bipedal beasts show what happens
when a mammal converges on the predatory
megafaunal niche of the T-Rex when a
driver runs their thick claws dig into
the cold Earth for purchase in their
powerful hind legs allow them to pursue
prey across the flat Tundra with ease
few creatures on soulcash are as feared
the final region of soulcash is also the
largest the deep ocean
's currently cover over 70 percent of
our planet's surface and if given rise
to some of the most extraordinary
species on Earth and in the era of the
soulcash bastiary ocean life has never
been more spectacular
skimming over the waves in great flying
Shoals the tiama feed on swarms of
hovering insects with their elongated
mouths and Keen eyesight these fish are
expert bug catchers perhaps
unsurprisingly the tiama are related to
Flying Fish although tiama are far more
aggressive if a Shoal of these fish is
sufficiently threatened the Swarm
becomes hostile slashing Predators with
their razor-sharp fins in consecutive
flybys
on the Stony beaches of the soulcash
coast the daogon Basques in the seaside
Sun these peculiar mammals possess large
dorsal sails to regulate their
temperature and to attract mates the
dalgon is another relative of the hippo
having taken their semi-aquatic
lifestyle to new extremes their thick
layers of blubber allow them to survive
the frigid depths of the sea floor a
streamlined body makes for a quick
descent to the ocean floor to forage a
trip the dalgon must make daily to
maintain their bulk
one of the greatest Monsters of all
lurks near the surface through six eyes
rising over the choppy waves in search
of prey the archeopty is a large
crustacean that stealthily Treads water
with their petal like limbs keeping
their body hidden until it's time to
strike despite their impressive size
these creatures are most closely related
to current day shrimp when prey lands
close to the archeopty they release a
mucus covered Shard of stone at their
target then drag their fresh meal below
the waves
the soulcash bastiary offers an
inventive interpretation of Life In the
far future yet in addition to being a
speculative Evolution project this
bestiary is also available for DND with
sheets for all the creatures up on the
artist's patreon as well as 3D printing
files made in collaboration with Edge
Miniatures once again there are links to
follow and support the artist Terry
Miranda in the description below
[Music]
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video